eh ben dis donc professeur cabu est ce
que tu as déjà vu des caméras folle
jamais vue de caméra fall mais j'ai vu
des photos floues salfo fait faux bon
d'accord mais nous avons fait de bons
albums de famille et au hasard oui je
sais pas si tu vas savoir reconnaître
les photos de ma famille
alors là c'est ce que c'est ça c'est un
déjeuner sur l'herbe mais un prix un peu
trop haut doit cadrer un peu trop
alors après cadrer un peu trop bas tu
vois ça c'est une vache c'est ce que
c'est ça elle c'était un déjeuner sur
l'herbe pour assister à l'envol d'une
montgolfière alors la montgolfière elle
est cachée derrière le pid
bon après je continue c'est ce que c'est
ça c'est pas une sorte de prison et
célébrant de bourdes une majorette un
prix adapté trop près parce que j'ai mis
au lieu de mettre lointain gmi gros plan
bon après faut absolument pas cadré
comme il faut tu sais ce que c'est ça ça
un pas à pas rapides
non non attendez je vais t'en parce que
j'ai fait une série de photos là qui me
plaisait bien toujours des photos chance
oui et ça
c'est le même alors ça c'est la palier
en palier
ça c'est la pelote basque et chistera
s'appelle froid oui et ça c'est coucher
de soleil toi on voit le soleil qui est
dans le roman s'appelle ça après celle
aide-moi de quoi c'est pas terrible on
peut pas dire eh bien merci professeur
cabu tu m'excuses parce que j'ai rendez
vous avec ma copine
jeanne et aujourd'hui ça commence assez
mal attachez vos ceintures
[Musique]